[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
france 24 mi nombre es álvaro cordero
este 2 de abril se cumplen 40 años del
inicio de la guerra de las malvinas un
conflicto entre argentina y reino unido-
iniciado por la soberanía sobre este
archipiélago conocido por los británicos
como folklore que generó cientos de
muertos y una crisis internacional sin
precedentes en la región en la crónica
de historia de esta semana profundizamos
en las causas de esta guerra su
desarrollo y las consecuencias que
perduran hasta la actualidad la
reclamación de argentina se extiende
desde el año 1833 sobre el archipiélago
de las malvinas y las islas georgias del
sur y sandwich del sur una serie de
territorios situados en la parte más
austral del continente sudamericano que
poseen un gran valor estratégico pero
que a pesar de su cercanía a las costas
argentinas son considerados un
territorio de ultramar de londres con
estos antecedentes históricos se llegó a
abril de 1982 argentina estaba bajo el
poder de una dictadura militar comandada
por leopoldo galtieri
gobierno sufría un profundo desprestigio
por la crisis económica e inflación que
azotaban a la nación austral y por los
casos de graves violaciones a los
derechos humanos contra opositores
galtieri y su entorno consideraron que
una invasión a las malvinas elevaría la
popularidad de su gobierno y terminaría
con las críticas
su otro punto fuerte para iniciar la
operación era la creencia de que reino
unido no respondería a la captura de un
territorio situado a casi 13 mil
kilómetros de londres por aquella época
reino unido- estaba gobernado por la
conservadora margaret thatcher y
atravesaba una profunda crisis interna
por la reconversión industrial que había
llevado a huelgas generales constantes
de obreros y mineros en toda la nación
pero galtieri se equivocó y su plan de
anexión de las malvinas se convirtió en
una guerra aunque sus tropas tomaron las
malvinas y las georgias del sur en dos
días reino unido declaró la guerra y
envió a 30.000 efectivos el 5 de abril
dos portaaviones británicos junto a
varios buques de guerra y destructores
recorrieron el atlántico para repeler la
operación militar argentina además
mientras galtieri contó con tímidos
apoyos en américa latina' y la urss
reino unido- tuvo el firme respaldo de
eeuu francia y chile por su parte
argentina desplegó 10.000 hombres en las
malvinas y puso en acción por primera
vez en su historia a la fuerza aérea
está decidida como el pueblo argentino
si quieren venir que vengan les presenta
mi nueva talla
iniciada la guerra reino unido- logró
hacerse con las georgias del sur el 25
de abril de 1982 y hundió la nave
argentina general belgrano el 2 de mayo
provocando uno de los mayores desastres
de la guerra y la muerte de 323
militares argentinos el ejército
británico se centró en destruir el
aeropuerto de stanley la capital de las
malvinas y proteger a los dos
portaaviones enviados argentina logró
dañar varios buques de guerra pero no
los portaaviones mientras que reinó
unido- destruyó alrededor del 30 por
ciento de las aeronaves argentinas el
mando militar británico era consciente
de que podía perder la guerra si ésta se
prolongaba y que la única oportunidad
que tenía de finalizar la era realizar
una gran operación por tierra para ello
el 21 de mayo comenzó un desembarco por
el norte de la isla soledad para rodear
stanley lugar donde se concentraba el
mayor número de argentinos durante
semanas se produjeron intensos combates
cuerpo a cuerpo que dejaron decenas de
muertos aunque a pesar de la tenaz
resistencia argentina
prioridad británica hizo que stanley
quedara bajo sitio en unos días las
condiciones del ejército argentino
desplegado en las malvinas durante la
guerra fueron deplorables
buenos aires- no se preocupó por
proporcionar suministros básicos a sus
soldados que portaron armamento
defectuoso y carecían de ropa adecuada
para soportar el duro invierno en estas
islas además muchas de estas personas
eran jóvenes sin apenas experiencia de
combate las unidades de élite del
ejército de tierra argentino no fueron
desplegadas en malvinas ya que la
mayoría no estaban en la frontera con
chile debido al miedo que existía a una
invasión de augusto pinochet
abiertamente enfrentado con argentina
para esa época con su ejército rodeado
el 2 de junio argentina intentó dar un
último golpe a la armada británica a
través de la operación encubierta
algeciras que tenía el objetivo de
hundir la flota de reino unido-
desplegada en la base de gibraltar pero
también fracasó precipitando el
inevitable final de la contienda la dura
derrota fue un shock para argentina y
especialmente para el gobierno militar
que quedó totalmente desprestigiado y
cayó definitivamente en 1983 dando paso
a la democracia en total 649 argentinos
murieron en la guerra mientras que los
fallecidos británicos fueron 255 por su
parte la figura de margaret thatcher
creció en popularidad forjando su figura
de dama de hierro y ganando las
elecciones al año siguiente la victoria
fue recibida con júbilo en reinounido
pero el conflicto nunca se cerró
argentina sigue considerando que las
malvinas son parte de su soberanía y
continúa realizando reclamaciones sobre
éstas a pesar de la negativa mostrada
por londres y por los habitantes
insulares que prefieren continuar
ligados a la corona británica una
cuestión que dificulta que las
aspiraciones de argentina puedan
materializarse en el corto plazo con
esto concluimos gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
[Música]